before we move on from ukraine i wanted
to check in and i think this this is
worthy of being the top headline for us
today in the five headlines i want to
check in with a voice of reason on the
ukraine subject uh someone who
i think we were all kind of waiting and
like i've already i've already said it i
i don't know a whole lot about about the
issue myself and most people don't and
so we're waiting for voices of authority
people who
know what they're talking about and are
very well read and have studied this
subject we're waiting for them to kind
of
you know guide us give us a little bit
of guidance and finally yesterday we got
that listen to this
the phone is not hacked it's really me i
actually want to say a lot of things but
i'm just going to mind my business
because
sometimes i feel like i have such a big
platform that
if i say if i don't say the right things
i might get killed but i'm really not on
nato's side i'm really not in russian
side
i'm actually in the citizen side because
at the end of the day the world is
having a crisis right now there's
inflation not only in america but
everywhere in the world
it's really hard to get um
the economy back up
there is so much shipments and
embarkments backed up
china's not really messing with us so a
lot of things are behind a lot of goods
are behind and this [ __ ] just made it
way more complicated so i'm just really
annoyed by this and i really wish that
all world leaders right now just really
come with a logical conclusion but
whatever
i mean she raises some good points uh as
she says so so much shipments and
embarkments backed up
um i don't know i'm not sure if those
are even words but
uh and chyna's not really messing with
us she points out i mean you could say
that they are kind of messing with us
and that they unleashed a virus on the
world
that killed five million people you know
they kind of messed with us that way but
um either way that's that's her uh
that's her take and you know what that
is
what i'll say about it at least
is that it is at least as coherent
and meaningful as anything we've heard
from the administration about this issue
that actually made
mo i'm not going to say it made a lot of
sense but it made more sense
comparatively than uh than the clip we
played
of gem pasaki
saying that we have to we have to get
involved for our values
so
you know who's whose side are you gonna
take cardi b or jen pasake those are the
only two sides available i'm afraid does
it make sense that the same company who
controls half of online retail also
passively eavesdrops on your private
conversations at home what about the
idea that a single company controls 90
of internet searches runs your email
service and gets to track everything you
do on your smartphone big tech is more
powerful than most countries are and
they profit by exploiting your personal
data it's time to put a layer of
protection between your online activity
and these tech giants and that's why i
use expressvpn think about how much of
your life is on the internet sadly every
site you visit video you watch message
you send gets tracked and data mined but
when you run expressvpn on your device
the software hides your ip address
something big tech can use to personally
identify you so expressvpn makes your
activity harder to trace and also harder
to sell to advertisers expressvpn also
encrypts 100 of your internet data to
keep you safe from hackers and
eavesdroppers on your network as well so
stop handing over your personal data to
the big tech monopoly who minds your
activity and sells your information
protect yourself with the vpn i trust to
keep me safe
visit expressvpn.com
matt walsh show to get three extra
months free
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated